evangelical Christians around the world
waited and again the end did not count
so some believers reinterpreted the
prophecy they propose that the
Antichrist must desecrate the temple in
Jerusalem before Jesus would return but
there is a problem there is no temple to
desecrate the Romans acted in 70 AD so
in order for Jesus to return the temple
must be rebuilt in the way is the Dome
of the rock the third most holy mosque
for Muslims but raising it would risk
holy
Jesus has to come back and we want him
to come back soon and he can't come back
to the temple is rebuilt so get the heck
out of the way and let us rebuild the
temple
that's the desta mentality but it's
powerful its prolific it's our religion
it's our culture and it's sacred to us
Christian groups donate millions of
dollars a year to Israel and nowhere is
that support stronger than in the United
States where evangelical beliefs
continue to gain in popularity
millions of young Americans today
believe they are living in the last days
the Second Coming is near
in megachurches like guts Church in
Tulsa Oklahoma the message of Revelation
is being preached in all new ways
see
that you know would be
when we started the church we just
thought about taking our approach to
younger people and to people that
weren't attractive to church you've got
to make it enticing to them you got to
make it attractive to
churches like this one preach that the
book of Revelation is perfectly clear
God will condemn non-believers to
eternal hell and bless believers with
everlasting life
like I don't I don't have a shred of
doubt right now that we're in the end
times things change so rapidly and
things are becoming so intense and
things are so are so passionate today
that that something happened has to
happen